with politics and president trump says
he will show up for thursday night's
second
and final presidential debate but he is
not happy about the recent changes
there will be a mute button during this
debate organizers announced
new rules that give president trump and
joe biden
two uninterrupted minutes to answer
questions at the start of each segment
now during that time the other
candidate's microphone will be turned
off
president trump claims the commission on
presidential debates
is against him these people are
not good people this commission a lot of
funny things go on with them
the president says he is also unhappy
the night will include topics beyond the
debate's original focus
foreign policy he says he still does
plan to attack
biden over his son hunter's business
deals both in ukraine and in china
for its part the biden campaign said
president trump is afraid to face more
questions about his disastrous covet
response
and is more concerned with the rules of
the debate than getting a nation in
crisis
the help it needs again that's coming up
thursday night